the grand chest or does feature to
classical chess tournaments and five
rapid and blitz right and some new rapid
a blitz as well and one of those new
events is in Romania yes and we can
announce that the wildcards for Romania
super bet rapid and blitz as bloody slap
artemyev like lick one here and anton
core above these exciting players yeah I
have to say you know very nice choices
winner of Gibraltar you know I think
Alexander Christian could in the Chuck
Norris the Russian team the cranium of
course you know it's a fantastic
fantastic player
Anton horrible yeah just to say a few
words I didn't say it again I'll tell me
F thank you that was what I wanted to
hear really up-and-coming player he is
really bold
I love his dynamic style of play we just
had our summer classic here at the st.
Louis chess club and liam won the
tournament so big shout out to him and
then anton has really a very very very
strange style he he can score incredibly
well I saw him in vikon's a and these B
groups doing incredible things you know
running up massive scores he does all
three she did fantastically well in the
insert world masters rapid and blitz in
China in China yeah I mean he just
demolished the program position and we
also have is a drumroll we found
effective and here are the wild cards
for the India so we have Pantani Hari
Krishna and Santosh vid it
oh you know this of India's absolute
absolute top players on their Olympic
teams
hurry krishna is is really in the top
well I want to say top 30 top 40 for
quite a number of years very very
differently he almost won Shenzhen I
think in Danish Gary snatched that's the
first prize last round and did it he's
been around is super super talent
solidified himself in the top of Indian
chess and also I mean absolutely you
know outcomes to the openings highly
prepared and here is the ground chess
torts jia jiao so first up we have paris
wrapping and blitz and that starts July
26 and followed by heavy well st. Loup
no we're so happy to host the I like to
say rhythm and blues tournaments rapid
in blitz and then comes our second and
final classical event the Sinquefield
cup considered by many the strongest
tournaments since the Pieta course the
white helps to ever be played on
American soil
yeah that is just you know a highlight
for Americans in the calendar and the
new events in Bucharest Romania and and
blitz and then of Steel and in Kolkata
and then followed by the grand Chester
finals your home my home city London yes
as once again London will it will be the
final force the top four players will go
and play elimination matches as we saw
last year